[Musique]
bonjour tu as trouvé quelque chose mon sentiment
de paix d'accord maintenant tu vas trop loin
maintenant je t'ai dit que nous devons détruire Beulah
combien de temps dois-je rester là
à te corriger d'accord nous sommes l'ensemble des
Avengers j'ai eu de la chance  assez
avec d'autres gardiens de la galaxie pour
rejoindre les Avengers et être ici
et avoir l'opportunité de sauver le monde
est-ce que cela fait de vous un Avenger maintenant aussi
je ne sais pas peut-être comme une troisième chaîne
d'ender ouais était l'un des  les
membres fondateurs ouais merci il est énorme
vous savez de toutes les personnes avec qui j'ai
eu la chance de travailler avec ces
deux gars en particulier et le triumvirat
que nous avons formé ensemble
c'est une amitié très spéciale et des décennies
ensemble ça a été ça
être témoin de la vie de gens qui
grandissent et changent, c'était une
expérience vraiment cool de travailler avec Lizzie,
c'était vraiment génial et je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose de très puissant
à pouvoir jouer des femmes qui font des
choses héroïques et  ces femmes sont tellement géniales, donc
nous avons passé un très bon moment à passer du temps
avec tout le monde sur le plateau est l'une des
meilleures parties de ce travail en fait parce
qu'il a ce genre de sensation de grande
famille élargie j'ai eu un peu un seau de
quelqu'un vaut la peine de s'entraîner, je pensais qu'il
serait très amusant, je me suis complètement trompé
sur ce front, il était étrange Lluis et
ennuyeux et pas particulièrement drôle bien
au début Blanche, il est difficile de savoir
quoi faire un Cumberbatch et puis plus de
temps j'ai passé  avec lui sur et hors plateau, je suis
juste un peu épris de ce gars,
je pensais que vous connaissiez le voyage de
Robert Downey jr.  est fait, il est le
parrain de tout cela, c'est littéralement
l'aventure d'une
vie.